comes back with an image that you can
order as a t-shirt or something like
this but the core of that is very simple
you know there's no database behind that
there's there's no really results to
come back to the only thing about it
takes a few seconds so maybe it's not a
snappy a snappy thing but overall it's a
it's a fun little website it works well
so there's a there's a state list do I
have state do I does my output depend on
anything other than some input that's
directly coming in from a web request
there's you know the number of visitors
you have the amount of traffic you have
when a visitor arrives at your website
how many requests are involved do you
have static content mypie day and image
identify both have you know some HTML
pages some normal web front-end static
content and then they have some active
content in the back the active content
is mostly what we're interested in
that's where our server-side Wolfram
language code lives but you when you're
developing a web app you what you do
want to think about what's my static
content we have if you have state then
how much data are you talking about you
know you have a site like an enormous
site like YouTube where there's a vast
quantity of data and any particular
video you want a view has to locate it
has to start streaming it so the the
image identify site has has the ability
once you've uploaded some image the
image identify has never seen before and
it works on it it runs you know some
some recognition on it and it comes up
with a result people might like to share
it either because it's ridiculously
wrong or because it's cool so the
sharing of it is interesting you know
with my PI day you share your result you
you know it's probably acceptable for
somebody you share with to spend a few
seconds recomputing image identify we
don't I'll do that so we store results
so you want to start thinking about when
I'm writing my up
locations you know my storing results
how are they with those being retrieved
and then there's question of its another
aspect which is concurrency I have you
know I post my link to my great thing I
developed I get 50,000 visitors all at
once can anything go wrong and for some
things like my pi day the answer is the
only thing that would go wrong is you
you overwhelm the cloud somehow now our
public cloud is designed to Auto scale
so the more demand we get the more nodes
are put into service and there there are
some being held in reserve so it all
kind of works well but if you if you
have interactions between your users if
you're writing a social social
networking site then there's some
contention to think about how do you
handle that the there's an interesting
architecture for tweeted program the
idea of tweet a program is I tweet at a
certain point Witter user Wolfram tap
and the content of my tweet is taken as
code to be run in on a Wolfram cloud the
way that works is you've got a
background task running in the Wolfram
cloud that is that is continually
checking asking Twitter is there you
know is anybody talking about me you
know is anybody tweeting at Wolfram tap
and from from that input gathering
mechanism it will spawn out handling
individual tweets so an individual tweet
is found and then a this background task
makes an API request within the cloud to
handle the tweet and get our content I
was going to really start with a
motivating example which is this
application that I worked on for a few
hours last week and there is hopefully I
see a blinking cursor I just don't see
my mouse pointer somebody so what we've
got here I've published this chat site
it's in the talk notes if you want to go
here right now with your laptop's its
Wolfram cloud comm slash objects and
my username jf Klein JFK le I n slash
cloud chat slash chat dot HTML and I've
got a shortened URL if I could get to my
to my talk alright so what does happen
when I typed help my my JavaScript code
got an event it did an ajax call to the
Wolfram cloud uploaded the content of my
chat server-side added it to a data
structure a JavaScript script requested
are there any new chats and fetched my
new chat from there from the server so
it was round-tripping if people are
really piling on here then then we would
see you know we would see more activity
if there was a lot more we would be
seeing you know constant updates so this
is this is an example where we have lots
of users
lots of API requests going on this is
not your your mypie day where this or
there's a single single calculation this
is more about you know moving data back
and forth so there's some interesting
things we can do here
I will now that I've got this back I
will actually know let's go to the
source
so I've put the source up here so you
can take a look the server-side code I
want to show what's happening there so
when a new check comes in this write
chat function while we're doing the way
we're storing these these chats is in a
single dot M file that's got a bunch of
associations one after another so when
we reach rat we when we read chats we're
doing a realist we're getting in a list
of associations there's our data the
association's are on the JavaScript side
or JSON so they're easy to work with but
here's where we're creating our data and
this there's there's not too much to it
there's an ID and the time and the time
zone the time and time zone are
interesting it's being the time is being
normalized to GMT here when you request
the chat your your request is being
localized by the kernel so if you're in
France actually if we're here this is
already we're already seeing that this
is doing what it's supposed to do
because these times should be local to
Champaign so when we when we're
retrieving it back we we localize these
according to the current time zone so
time zone for the requester is always
set to where they are what their
geolocation is so we have an opportunity
to add some things here we could add
things about based on some metadata that
we have about who's who's calling we
could add their geolocation we could add
what country and city they're from we
could look up entity properties about
where they are so there's this this
simple little app gives you might give
you a lot of ideas about interesting
ways to extend this or interesting
places to go from here you know I
thought of a you know conversations
starter mode where it randomly picks an
entity property about your country and
says you know
23 million phones in my country about
yours
so there's a lots of things we could do
here so I will since we we talked about
these properties a little bit and we
referenced some of the some of the
applications one thing I didn't mention
was data drops so a couple words about
that as an example of an application so
let's do small ok I don't know what
happened to the stylesheet because I
definitely worked on the stylesheet to
make this all bigger and they're not
bigger but that was easy
so data drop you can almost think of it
as a service or as a platform you can
build up things on data drop there you
have the idea that you know you have
connected devices Internet of Things and
they they or anything you want to build
can put data into a data bin
periodically however you want and then
retrieve it so you here you've got an
idea of its it's definitely stateful and
input that you give into it like get me
the contents of my data bin does not
depend on just the input it depends on
the state of your persistent store your
backing store what's in the bin so it's
it's a little more complicated there was
a blog post from wolfram recently after
we got some new coffee machines in the
office and they came with these nifty
little cartridges where he could pick a
flavor so the idea was let's give people
a way to rate these flavors and the
flavor Reiter app has a couple
interesting things about it first of all
the the input is gathered by a form so
you fill out this form you pick you know
which flavor you know we we didn't like
the French Roast
sorry if I'm messing up your data or
known so what this what that form did
when I ran it is it dropped is it
dropped to my selection into this data
been the data bins now collecting
information from all the users that
visit this and that output was generated
by visiting the entire bin and
summarizing it at once
so that's good when you've got of you
know fifty hundred people in the office
that try this out but that doesn't scale
super well if you're taking you know
political surveys or something like that
for millions of people so something you
might need to think about as you're
designing something like this is gosh I
might need to aggregate as I go have a
schedule task that runs through my my
data and does summaries like this or
every time I drop something in you know
update a Mena media and something like
that so these are the types of things
that I'm hoping to you know get across
and we talked about tweet a program so I
wanted to spend a second looking at you
know the magnification is killing me so
we'll go back for a second there's a lot
to say about the model the environment
that you're programming in and this
picture is worth quite a few of those
words about the model this is very basic
on the Left we have a variety of clients
that can be coming from a variety of
different sources browsers Mathematica
desktop counts as a client is like the
cloud export cloud deploy those commands
are all clients that hit the cloud
mobile device counts as a client and on
the right side we have we have a model
of the cloud so let's just trace an
interaction let's say we ran our coffee
flavor rater
just now in our browser so this red line
represents that a a web request came
into the cloud as it hit the cloud it
hits a load balancer that looks to see
have I heard from this user before you
know the the IP a
ress and and so on are taken into
account and what cookies are coming in
with this request if I see that there's
no session cookie I create one once the
session is created for user sessions are
routed to the same node in the cloud for
the life of that session so load
balancer decides that this request goes
to this particular node further requests
will also go to this node so here's a
blow-up of here's the node detail so we
have a web server that that work that
were request hits it has access to
several resources it has access to
kernels Wolfram language kernels has
access to a local disk on that node and
also has access to a network available
filesystem or at a network available
service that is accessible within the
cloud so there's a couple of things to
point out while we're looking at this
still one is when you're thinking about
Layton sees and time one thing to be
aware of is time from Internet to the
cloud and another one is network time
within the cloud so in the in the case
of something like tweet a program you
might have a background task doing work
on one node that makes an API request
within the cloud that's going to be a
lot faster than your connection so these
are all things I think you want to know
as you're designing designing
applications so there are several kernel
types the ones that we typically care
about when we're writing these web
applications are the public and the
service public is used for these cloud
objects that are not static so those are
would be the API function of the form
function delayed we're getting some new
ones there's a grammar rule so anything
that requires evaluation goes to this
public kernel type and services for
scheduled tasks and that family of
things where it's not actually connected
to
web requests you can create a schedule
task through the web but when it runs it
runs sort of behind the scenes there's
there's no interaction with the browser
or anything like that so a couple a
couple things worth noting here what
note and kernel am I on so we'll go back
to back to zoom so you may have used
machine ID process I need to find out
where you're running locally if you do a
cloud evaluate this is very similar to
running an API function this runs on a
public kernel if I ask it to evaluate
that in the cloud I'm not connected
probably it'll come back and tell you
with some some hostname some process ID
now if you evaluate that again watch the
process ID you may get a different
number and if I run that repeatedly and
tally them up you can see that there
were four unique the same node before
you need kernels so this is just
experimenting and discovering that model
we were looking at before
there are several kernels on that node
that are dedicated to this type of thing
the exact number here may change over
time so may not always be for maybe a
lot more
probably not less and these things are
all reconfigurable in a private cloud
another thing worth noting is API
overhead I'm only mentioning it because
I've spent so much blood sweat and tears
over the past while working on this
particular aspect this is just you know
when you call an API function you know
how long does it take from the time it
hits the cloud to the time your code is
running a year ago that number was not
so wonderful now it's pretty good and
we're you're not going to notice that
you're gonna be seeing network latency
much much bigger than than that overhead
just a brief word about this because I
think has been covered pretty well but
when you think about writing your code
and when it's running in the cloud you
want to be aware that you can access you
can use normal file operations the you
know copy file
you know export you can use normal file
operations and you can also use
operations through cloud object wrappers
your home directory files are accessible
either way other users cloud objects are
only accessible through the cloud object
wrappers so one thing that sometimes
happens it is the case right now that
the direct file system access is going
to be faster than accessing through a
cloud object and if you've got anything
that's sort of sensitive to time you'll
notice that so a strategy to deal with
that is if you've got a cloud object
that's going to live for a while created
as a cloud object and then update it or
read it directly through a normal file
system operation so in my chat
application the the the backing file
that holds the chats was created as a
cloud object sort of when we created the
chat room but then after that just read
list you know
normal file operations and just to just
a debugging note a couple of things can
go wrong with when dealing with cloud
objects content can be wrong so anything
that you're used to you know examining
the content of a file applies to cloud
objects you can file print it can run
yet you can run binary read list if
you're suspecting like this new lines
are wrong or something but meta
information can also be wrong the mime
type you know I I cloud put an API
function and when I try to retrieve it
it doesn't run well if you will the
mistake there is cloud put just creates
an expression and that's marked as an
expression by its mime type and if you
look at the mime type you'll see it ends
in the word expression if you cloud
deploy an API function it ends in
expression dot API
it's that expression dot API makes all
the difference makes the difference
between serving it as an expression
there's just some text and running it as
active code so do look at options of a
cloud object and cloud object
information which has even more
information about a cloud object I
should mention the kernel sandbox
if you try to access a file that's not
in your home directory or sort of one of
the temporary directory or one of these
things that's sort of yours the kernel
will act as if the file doesn't exist
even if it's there on the server trying
to import the password file the kernel
just acts like it doesn't exist and
generally right now running binaries
that you provide is not allowed and I
wish that we're not the case we're
looking at ways to get it so that we can
have a secure system that you can you
know that you can be sure that you're
protected from a malicious user but at
the same time allow you to do things
like use the you know compiled functions
you'll see company accelerated compiled
functions we can't do that in the cloud
right now though I'm gonna skip the rest
of
the rest of this and just point you to
the the cloud execution metadata guide
page because I want to I want to leave
time for at least one question so I'll
Lam there